This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Humans and birds don't have much in common. For example, most birds can fly, and most humans can't. But one thing we do have in common is that humans and birds both love to play tourists in New York City. Every year, millions of birds fly to New York on their annual migration, and because flying several thousand miles is pretty exhausting,
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。人类和鸟类没有太多共同点。例如，大多数鸟类会飞，而大多数人类不会。但我们确实有一个共同点，那就是人类和鸟类都喜欢去纽约市当游客。每年，数百万只鸟儿在一年一度的迁徙中飞往纽约，由于飞行数千英里相当累人，
these birds nest for a few days in one of NYC's many urban parks. I live really near Book and Bidge Park and I've basically walked in the park almost every day of the pandemic. But I always saw it through the eyes of, you know, somebody who's an architecture critic, but I'd never really perceived it as a bird habitat. This is Design Critic in front of the show, Alexander Lang. I would see people, you know, tweeting pictures of birds from Brooklyn Ridge Park.
这些鸟儿会在纽约市众多城市公园中的某一个栖息几天。我住得离布鲁克林大桥公园非常近，在大流行期间，我几乎每天都在公园里散步。但我看待它的视角始终是一个建筑评论家的视角，我从来没有真正把它当作鸟类的栖息地来感知。这位是节目常驻设计评论家亚历山大·朗。你知道的，我会看到人们在推特上发布来自布鲁克林大桥公园的鸟类照片。
And so I'd think, oh, I should, you know, notice those. But I just, it's like I didn't know how to notice them. Alexander wanted to know more about the birds passing through her city And wrote an article about it for the website city lab last November She emailed two local birders and they showed her all the birds quietly nesting in her favorite park And then we have the Ravens nest to do about that This is the Ravens nested on the tower of the Proconvrede about that. So the Ravens nested on the tower of the Procuretion. Oh, that's the third, the third ever on record Raven nest. They shown me this bird that they call the Butterbutt.
所以我想，哦，我应该注意一下这些。但我就觉得，我好像不知道该怎么去注意到它们。亚历山大想更多地了解路过她城市的鸟类，并在去年 11 月为 CityLab 网站写了一篇关于这的文章。她给两位当地的观鸟者发了电子邮件，他们向她展示了所有静静在她最喜欢的公园里筑巢的鸟类。然后我们有关于这个的渡鸦巢吗？这是在普罗库雷蒂翁塔楼上筑巢的渡鸦。所以渡鸦在普罗库雷蒂翁塔楼上筑巢。哦，那是第三个，有记录以来第三个渡鸦巢。他们向她展示了这只他们称之为“黄屁股”的鸟。
Oh, I see. Okay. So like, some people call them Butterbutt. Its real name is the yellow romp warbler, this FYI. I don't know if that's any more dignified than butter but, you know. It was so fun to see just that like, flash of bright yellow in the park. You know, it was already November, like everything was very gray and brown and kind of sear. And just to have somebody point and see that like, flash of yellow, that was just great.
哦，我明白了。好吧。所以，有些人管它们叫“黄屁股”。顺便说一句，它的真名是黄腰林莺。我不知道这是否比“黄屁股”更尊贵一点。看到公园里闪过那一抹亮黄色真的很有趣。你知道，当时已经是 11 月了，一切都变得灰蒙蒙、棕褐色，还有点枯黄。只要有人指出来并让你看到那一抹黄色，那就太棒了。
But as Alexander walked to the park, she noticed something else, something that unnerved her. While Brooklyn Bridge Park is a safe haven for birds, the park is surrounded by condos and hotels and office buildings with floor-to-sealing windows. These all glass building facades are the absolute worst for migrating birds. Because unlike people, birds don't really understand glass. I mean, this has happened in cities all over the US and all over the world. That there's been this boom in urban parks, but those parks' booms also spur real estate development. It's glass buildings because those are what we think of as fancy new architecture.
但当亚历山大走向公园时，她注意到了另一件事，一件让她感到不安的事。虽然布鲁克林大桥公园是鸟类的避难所，但公园四周环绕着落地窗的公寓、酒店和办公楼。这些全玻璃建筑的外立面对于迁徙的鸟类来说简直是灾难。因为与人类不同，鸟类并不真正理解玻璃。我的意思是，这在全美和世界各地的城市都发生过。城市公园迎来了繁荣，但这些公园的繁荣也刺激了房地产开发。这就是玻璃建筑，因为这是我们所认为的时髦新建筑。
Anytime you have glass and birds in the same space, you have a risk of bird window collisions. This is Caitlin Parkins, the interim director of conservation and science at New York City Audubon. I often hear people say, oh birds are so dull and they just run into glass. Why don't they see it? And if you step back and think of it, it's made not to be seen, right? It's made so that we can look through our window and get a beautiful view of the outdoors. We see glass because we use architectural cues to
任何时候，只要玻璃和鸟类出现在同一个空间里，就会有鸟类撞击玻璃的风险。这位是纽约奥杜逊学会的保护与科学代理主任凯特琳·帕金斯。我经常听到人们说，哦，鸟太笨了，它们怎么就撞到玻璃上了呢？它们怎么看不到？如果你退一步想想，它就是为了不被看见而制造的，对吧？它的制造是为了让我们能透过窗户欣赏户外的美丽风景。我们能看到玻璃是因为我们利用了建筑线索来
recognize that it's present, or we've learned some of the nuance of the color of glass or maybe there's a mark on the glass that makes us realize, okay, this is a solid barrier. Birds can't really pick up on those cues. This is especially bad if there's anything behind the glass. The bird recognizes like a plant. So if you can imagine a really reflective piece of glass and there's a tree in it. A bird is going to see that and recognize it as a tree and try to fly to it and they're very fast and they hit very hard and often they die instantly. Another example, this is an ecological trap, but we put vegetation behind glass. We love atrium with trees in them. We want to bring nature indoors. Well, then you're actually just putting a clear piece of glass between a tree and a bird. And of course, they're going to try
识别它的存在，或者我们了解了一些玻璃颜色的细微差别，或者也许玻璃上有个标记让我们意识到，好吧，这是一个坚固的屏障。鸟类并不能真正察觉到这些线索。如果玻璃后面有什么东西，情况就会特别糟糕。鸟类会认出像植物这样的东西。所以你可以想象一块反光效果很好的玻璃，里面有一棵树。鸟儿看到它就会把它认成一棵树，并试图飞向它，而且它们飞得非常快，撞击非常猛烈，通常会当场死亡。另一个例子，这是一个生态陷阱，但我们在玻璃后面放置了植被。我们喜欢里面有树的中庭。我们想把大自然带到室内。好吧，那么你实际上只是在树和鸟之间放置了一块透明的玻璃。当然，它们会试图
to fly to the tree and rest and hit the glass and potentially die. The world is incredibly perilous for birds, windmills kill birds, so do cars and trucks. And on top of that, pet cats kill so many birds, truly. Cats are out of control. However, it's believed that building collisions are one of the biggest causes of bird death. Birds crash into buildings during the day because they don't see the glass, and they run into buildings at night because they are lured in by artificial lighting. Most of these collisions happen below 100 feet because that's where birds are used to landing in trees. This loss is awful for so many reasons. Birds are essential for controlling pests and pollinating flowers and regenerating forests.
飞向那棵树并休息，结果撞到玻璃上并可能因此死亡。这个世界对鸟类来说极其危险，风力涡轮机会杀死鸟类，汽车和卡车也是如此。最重要的是，宠物猫杀死了大量的鸟类，真的。猫已经失控了。然而，人们认为建筑物碰撞是鸟类死亡的最大原因之一。鸟类在白天撞上建筑物是因为它们看不到玻璃，而在晚上撞上建筑物则是被人工照明吸引。大多数这类碰撞发生在 100 英尺以下的高度，因为那是鸟类习惯在树上着陆的地方。这种损失由于诸多原因而令人痛心。鸟类对于控制害虫、给花授粉和恢复森林至关重要。
And watching birds and listening to bird song is just really nice. We don't have exact numbers on how many birds we kill because there is no bird census But even the lowest estimates are devastating According to the Audubon Society buildings kill 300 million to a billion birds per year like a billion birds I mean, that's the high end of the estimate like these are definitely like I noticed when I was looking back through the stats Very broad estimates, but it's a lot of birds. These collisions are a major reason the bird population in North America is in decline.
而且观赏鸟类和聆听鸟鸣真的让人感觉非常美好。我们没有关于我们杀死了多少鸟类的准确数字，因为没有鸟类普查，但即使是最低的估计也是惊人的。根据奥杜逊学会的数据，建筑物每年杀死 3 亿到 10 亿只鸟，简直是一十亿只鸟。我的意思是，那是估计的高端，就像这些绝对是——当我回顾统计数据时，我注意到是非常广泛的估计，但确实有大量的鸟类。这些碰撞是北美鸟类数量下降的主要原因之一。
One study found that we've lost three billion birds since the 1970s. Again, we don't have exact numbers, which is why organizations around the world hold collision walks. Every week, groups like NYC Audubon organized volunteers to document the number of dead birds next to skyscrapers. Here's Caitlin Parkinson's. It started back in 1997 when one of our board members
一项研究发现，自 20世纪 70年代以来，我们已经失去了 30 亿只鸟。同样，我们没有确切的数字，这就是为什么世界各地的组织要举行碰撞巡查。每周，像纽约奥杜逊这样的组织都会组织志愿者记录摩天大楼旁死鸟的数量。这位是凯特琳·帕金斯。这一切始于 1997 年，当时我们的董事会成员之一
started just noticing dead birds on the sidewalk and actually didn't even know it was causing it. And she and some volunteers started walking the streets, documenting bird window collisions, picking up dead birds, and of course transporting injured birds to rehabilitation centers. So when our volunteers find a bird that's been stunned, they put it into a paper bag, and a paper bag is the best transport vehicle. They're like little bird ambulances. If you want to see this in action, there's a video on YouTube of Caitlyn helping stunned birds in a New York City park.
开始注意到人行道上有死鸟，甚至不知道是什么原因造成的。她和一些志愿者开始走上街头，记录鸟类撞击玻璃的事件，捡起死鸟，当然还将受伤的鸟类运送到康复中心。因此，当我们的志愿者发现一只被撞晕的鸟时，他们会把它放进纸袋里，纸袋是最好的运输工具。它们就像是小鸟救护车。如果你想亲眼看看，YouTube 上有一个视频，展示了凯特琳在纽约市的一个公园里帮助受惊的鸟儿。
Sort of let the bird out and let it choose to leave when it wants to. So I'm just going to open this bag. This bird is ready, ready, ready to go. Go ahead. There he goes. We actually don't know how many of those birds make it. We expect that many of them, even if they recover from the immediate trauma, probably have long-term trauma and probably often don't make it much further. According to Kaelin, stunned and wounded birds are the exception. Most birds that collide with buildings are killed instantly.
把鸟放出来，让它在想离开的时候自己选择离开。所以我现在要打开这个袋子。这只鸟已经准备好，准备好，准备出发了。去吧。它飞走了。我们实际上并不知道其中有多少鸟能挺过来。我们预计它们中的许多人，即使从直接的创伤中恢复过来，也可能会有长期的创伤，而且往往可能走不了太远。据凯特琳说，昏迷和受伤的鸟只是少数。大多数与建筑物相撞的鸟类都是当场死亡。
The Audemont volunteers spent a lot of their time picking up dead birds and bringing them back to a freezer at their office in Manhattan. Eventually, those carcasses get donated to museums for museum collections. It's kind of a nice way of having these birds go to some sort of useful scientific or educational purpose because they were needlessly killed, but it somehow feels a little bit better
奥杜逊的志愿者们花了很多时间捡拾死鸟，并把它们带回曼哈顿办公室的冰柜里。最终，这些尸体被捐赠给博物馆用于博物馆藏品。这算是一种不错的方式，让这些鸟儿去实现某种有用的科学或教育目的，因为它们是被无缘无故杀死的，但不知何故，感觉稍微好一点了
that at least they're going towards some greater good. Still, these collision walks are really difficult for the volunteers and staff at NYC Audubon. Caitlin Parkins vividly remembers a day last fall that lives in New York Berder, infamy. October 6th, 2021. There was really heavy migration. There was also a pretty intense storm and low cloud cover and that brings birds down low into the city. So I started getting text messages around 6.30 in the morning. So I started getting text messages around 6.30 in the morning. Volunteers were saying, I can't pick up all of these birds. I'm watching birds hit. I'm trying to pick up the stunned birds. I need help.
至少它们是为了某个更大的善举。尽管如此，对于纽约奥杜逊学会的志愿者和员工来说，这些碰撞巡查真的非常艰难。凯特琳·帕金斯清晰地记得去年秋天的一天，这一天在纽约观鸟界“声名狼藉”。2021年10月6日。那天的迁徙非常密集。当时还有一场相当猛烈的风暴和低矮的云层，这把鸟类压到了城市低空。所以我大约在早上 6 点半开始接到短信。所以我大约在早上 6 点半开始接到短信。志愿者们说，我捡不完所有这些鸟。我看着鸟撞上去。我正试图捡起那些被撞晕的鸟。我需要帮助。
I had a black pole warbler die in my hand. I watched it, hit a window at Columbus Circle, and I picked it up, and it was convulsing in my hand, and there's nothing that I could do in that moment. I knew that bird was going to die. The bird collisions that day were especially traumatic for volunteers in downtown Manhattan, particularly those who monitor the new towers at the World Trade Center site. Tower 4 is designed by Japanese architect Fumihiko Maki, and it's known as bird-anime number one because of its design. The tower is basically a floor-length mirror of a building, and it's an exactly the wrong place. The other aspect of why that particular site is deadly is the memorial grove of trees around
有一只黑poll林莺死在我的手里。我看着它撞上了哥伦布圆环的一扇窗户，我把它捡起来，它在我的手里抽搐，那一刻我什么也做不了。我知道那只鸟快要死了。那天发生的鸟类碰撞对曼哈顿市中心的志愿者来说尤其具有创伤性，特别是那些监测世贸中心遗址新塔楼的志愿者。4号楼由日本建筑师槙文彦设计，由于其设计被称为“1号鸟类杀手”。这座建筑基本上是一面整墙镜子，而且它处在一个完全错误的位置。那个特定地点之所以致命的另一个方面是围绕着
the footprint fountains for the deaths on 9-11. Those are a very broad tree canopy that's right in close proximity to these buildings. That morning, a volunteer for NYC Audubon named Melissa Breyer got to the World Trade Center buildings and what she found became big news around the world. That's a bird. They're being found. She went to the World Trade Center site and she found over 200 dead birds there that day.
9-11 遇难者纪念喷泉的纪念树林。这些树冠非常开阔，紧邻这些建筑。那天早上，一个名叫梅丽莎·布赖尔的纽约奥杜逊学会志愿者来到了世贸中心大楼，她发现的情况成了世界各地的大新闻。那是一只鸟。它们被发现了。她去了世贸中心遗址，那一天她在那里发现了 200 多只死鸟。
And she actually arranged them and kind of aggrid and attached the photos to the tweet. And I really think it went viral because seeing that many tiny, fragile, dead birds all in one tweet was just very overwhelming. It was picked up on Twitter, it was picked up by the media, we started getting all kinds of media inquiries as terrible as that event was. It brought a lot of awareness to the issue. This is clearly not an acceptable state of affairs. These are really some of the newest, shiniest buildings in New York.
她实际上把它们排列成网格状，并将照片附在推特上。我真的认为它之所以病毒式传播，是因为看到那么多微小、脆弱的死鸟都在一条推特上，实在是太震撼了。它被推特转发了，被媒体报道了，我们开始接到各种各样的媒体咨询，尽管那场事件很糟糕。它让人们对这个问题有了很大的认识。这显然是不可接受的现状。这些真的是纽约最新、最闪亮的建筑。
Why are we allowing them to do this to birds? When it comes to bird collisions, there's a lot we can do. For nighttime collisions, we can turn off lights and empty skyscrapers, which are tempting from migrating birds. And for daytime collisions, good design can go a long way. In fact, there are design solutions that can bring down bird deaths by 80% or 90%. And they're pretty straightforward. It's all about making buildings more legible for birds.
为什么我们要允许它们对鸟类做这种事？当谈到鸟类碰撞时，我们可以做很多事情。对于夜间碰撞，我们可以关掉灯光和空无一人的摩天大楼，这些对迁徙的鸟类来说具有极大的诱惑。对于日间碰撞，好的设计可以发挥很大作用。事实上，有一些设计方案可以将鸟类死亡率降低 80% 或 90%。而且它们非常简单直观。关键在于让建筑物对鸟类来说更加清晰可辨。
You can break up an all-glass facade with colored fins or solid barriers, or you can design a building with bird-safe glass that's covered in patterns or small dots, or bird doesn't see the glass as transparent. According to Alexander Lang, there are many great examples of bird-safe design on the New York skyline. Like, I think one of the best examples
你可以用彩色翅片或实体屏障来打破全玻璃外立面，或者你可以用覆盖着图案或小圆点的鸟类安全玻璃来设计建筑，这样鸟就不会把玻璃视为透明的了。根据亚历山大·朗的说法，纽约天际线上有许多鸟类安全设计的绝佳例子。比如，我认为最好的例子之一
is the New York Times Building, which was designed by Renzo Piano and has this exterior screen of ceramic rods, which are two inches or so apart. So that's a building that happens to be great for birds because they see the rods and they don't see the glass and so they don't smack into it. Today, many architects are consulting burgers while planning new buildings around the country.
就是纽约时报大楼，它由伦佐·皮亚诺设计，拥有由陶瓷棒组成的外遮阳屏，它们之间相距大约两英寸。所以这是一座对鸟儿很好的建筑，因为它们能看到杆子，看不到玻璃，所以它们不会撞上去。今天，许多建筑师在规划全国各地的新建筑时都在向观鸟者咨询。
One example is the Amazon campus that's being constructed in Northern Virginia. The original designs were less than ideal. The centerpiece of this new Amazon campus that they're building in Virginia is this building called the Helix, which is a curving glass building with a path spiraling up the outside and the whole path is going to be planted with trees. So for a bird that basically means at any point from the bottom to the top of the building,
一个例子是正在弗吉尼亚州北部建设的亚马逊园区。最初的设计并不那么理想。他们在弗吉尼亚州建设的新亚马逊园区的核心是一座名为“螺旋”的建筑，这是一座弯曲的玻璃建筑，外面有一条呈螺旋状上升的小路，整条小路都将种满树木。所以对于鸟类来说，这基本上意味着从建筑物的底部到顶部的任何一点，
they could easily get distracted, try to land on a tree and smack into the glass. Amazon hired a landscape architect named Kate Orf to work on the project. And right away, she noticed the serious problems with the facade. Kate Orf is a birder, is somebody that's been a real activist on bird safety, helped to write some earlier guidelines with Audubon Society. And so when she saw the design for this building, she was basically like, well, I can't be a party to this. See what you will about Amazon as a company, but they listened to Tukate Orph and the burgers on this one. All of the glass that is adjacent to the trees on this building
它们都很容易分心，试图在一棵树上着陆，然后砰的一声撞在玻璃上。亚马逊聘请了一位名叫凯特·奥尔夫的景观设计师来参与这个项目。很快，她就注意到了外立面的严重问题。凯特·奥尔夫是一名观鸟者，也是鸟类安全方面的真正活动家，曾协助奥杜逊学会编写了一些早期的指南。因此，当她看到这座建筑的设计时，她基本上觉得，好吧，我不能同流合污。不管你对亚马逊这家公司有什么看法，但在这一点上他们听取了凯特·奥尔夫和观鸟者的意见。这座建筑中所有靠近树木的玻璃
either has a frit or it's colored or there are external fins or spines that will be spaced, you know, two inches apart so that birds will perceive the building and not just smack into it. It's not just architects and planners getting wise to bird safety. Cities are also adopting new rules about bird safe design. Toronto approved regulations in 2010 that require new buildings to use 85% bird safe class on lower levels. And more recently, cities like New York and San Francisco have adopted similar rules.
要么有熔块，要么是有颜色的，或者有间距为两英寸的外侧翅片或脊柱，这样鸟类就能感知到建筑物，而不仅仅是撞上去。不仅仅是建筑师和规划师开始了解鸟类安全。城市也在采用关于鸟类安全设计的新规则。多伦多在 2010 年批准了相关法规，要求新建筑在低层使用 85% 的鸟类安全玻璃。最近，纽约和旧金山等城市也采用了类似的规则。
These new laws represent progress, but they can only do so much. And that's because these laws are focused on the design of new buildings. They don't address the thousands of glass structures that already exist. It's certainly much easier to design a bird-friendly building than to fix it later. Not that it's necessarily hard, it's just additional cost. Alexander Lang says there are only a few examples of buildings that have gone ahead with large-scale retrofits, including the Javits Center in Manhattan. It's a huge convention center that runs right along the West Side Highway next to a park.
这些新法律代表了进步，但它们的作用有限。这是因为这些法律侧重于新建筑的设计。它们没有解决已经存在的数千座玻璃结构的问题。设计一座对鸟类友好的建筑当然比事后修复要容易得多。倒不是说一定有多难，只是增加了额外的成本。亚历山大·朗表示，进行大规模改造的建筑只有少数几个例子，包括曼哈顿的贾维茨中心。这是一个巨大的会议中心，沿着西侧高速公路紧邻一个公园。
Javits used to be a notorious bird killer, but a few years ago, the owners invested millions of dollars to replace all the glass in the building. The new glass is covered in tiny dots spaced two inches apart. NYC Audubon says the renovations at Javits have reduced bird collisions by about 90 percent, but that's just for one building. Like I talked to several architects who know all about bird safety and even they in dealing with some clients can't convince them to use bird safe glass.
贾维茨过去是个臭名昭著的“鸟类杀手”，但几年前，业主投资数百万美元更换了建筑内的所有玻璃。新玻璃上覆盖着间距为两英寸的微小圆点。纽约奥杜逊学会表示，贾维茨中心的翻新工程将鸟类碰撞事件减少了大约 90%，但这只是一栋建筑。就像我跟几位对鸟类安全了如指掌的建筑师聊过的那样，甚至他们在与某些客户打交道时，也无法说服他们使用鸟类安全玻璃。
There is such a prejudice on the part of clients, especially clients who are building luxury buildings to think that they need Florida's ceiling transparent glass. And they think that the people that are gonna buy apartments in these buildings are not gonna be satisfied with glass that has tiny little dots on it. So they say, no, we're not gonna put that in, like we could live with the bird deaths. But Alexander Lang says, despite the resistance
客户方面存在着一种偏见，尤其是那些建造豪华建筑的客户，他们认为自己需要落地透明玻璃。他们认为在这些建筑中买公寓的人不会对带有小圆点的玻璃感到满意。所以他们说，不，我们不打算安装那个，就像我们可以忍受鸟类死亡一样。但亚历山大·朗表示，尽管来自设计者的阻力重重，
from designers, people get used to bird safe glass pretty quickly. It's really practically imperceptible to the human eye when you're inside the building that there are these teeny tiny dots on the glass. Even if there were laws to fix every skyscraper in America, it would only address a small part of the bird collision problem because our homes can have big glass windows too. And surprisingly, it's actually homes and low rise buildings that account for a majority
人们很快就会习惯鸟类安全玻璃。当你身处建筑内部时，人眼几乎察觉不到玻璃上有这些极小的圆点。即使有法律来修复美国每一座摩天大楼，它也只能解决鸟类碰撞问题的一小部分，因为我们的家也可能有巨大的玻璃窗。出人意料的是，实际上正是住宅和低层建筑占据了绝大多数
of bird collisions. Which begs the question, why are we talking about the high rises? Well, it's because a home or a low rise building is not going to kill 200 birds in one day. But there are so many more homes and low rise buildings in the U.S. than there are skyscrapers. So it's more the attrition of, say, your house with a big glass window killing 12 birds a year. But it turns out your neighbor's house also kills 12 birds a year, and the neighbor next to them and the neighbor next to them. The average person can't change the design of a skyscraper, but there are small fixes that can make your home bird safe.
的鸟类碰撞事件。这就引出了一个问题，为什么我们要讨论高层建筑？嗯，这是因为住宅或低楼层建筑不会在一天之内杀死 200 只鸟。但是在美利坚合众国，住宅和低层建筑的数量远远多于摩天大楼。所以这更多的是一种损耗，比如说你家带有大玻璃窗的房子每年杀死 12 只鸟。但事实证明，你邻居的房子每年也杀死 12 只鸟，还有他们隔壁的邻居以及隔壁的邻居。普通人无法改变摩天大楼的设计，但有一些小修补可以让你的家对鸟类安全。
If you say in your house have a big sliding glass door that birds keep running into, you can put stickers on that door. You can put a net over that door during prime flying season. At the very least, you should not install your bird feeder right in front of that giant glass door, because that makes it particularly deadly. So, yeah, there are a lot of inexpensive techniques that homeowners can use just to keep the birds away from their particular pain of glass. And that's what's so compelling about this issue, as opposed to the complex systemic interconnected issues that we often talk about on this show. Particlisions are a serious problem, but they pretty simple design solution.
如果你家里有一扇鸟类经常撞上去的大型推拉门，你可以在门上贴贴纸。在主要的飞行季节，你可以在门上盖上一张网。最起码，你不应该把鸟类喂食器直接安装在那个巨大的玻璃门前，因为那会让它变得格外致命。所以，是的，房主可以使用许多廉价的技术来让鸟类远离他们特定的玻璃窗。这就是这个问题的引人之处，与我们在这个节目中经常讨论的复杂的系统性相互关联的问题形成对比。鸟类碰撞是一个严重的问题，但它们有一个非常简单的设计解决方案。
The reason I love design is because design is about problem solving, and this is a problem we know how to solve. We just have to get over some of our aesthetic preoccupations in order to solve it. More words about birds with cur Colstad after this. So I'm back with 99PI's own Kurt Colstad to talk a little bit more about birds. Actually, there's quite a lot to talk about because over the years, we've gotten a lot of fan suggestions for stories on the subject of birds. Oh, yes, yes we have. And the funny thing is, back when I joined the show, like years ago, we actually had a rule on the books
我热爱设计的原因在于，设计关乎解决问题，而这是一个我们知道如何解决的问题。我们只需要克服某些审美偏好就能解决它。接下来的广告之后是库尔特·科尔斯塔德带来的更多关于鸟儿的话题。所以我回到了 99PI 的库尔特·科尔斯塔德身边，多聊聊鸟类。事实上，有很多事情可以聊，因为这些年来，我们收到了很多粉丝关于鸟类题材的故事建议。哦，是的，确实有很多。有趣的是，早在多年前我加入这个节目时，我们其实有一条明文规定的规矩
about 90-I-PI covering animal-related stories. The Cardinal Rule. No Cardinals. Exactly. The Cardinal Rule was no Cardinals. And that also applied to other animals. It was just kind of a fun shorthand. But since then, we've talked about a lot of species,
关于 99-I-PI 报道与动物相关的故事。核心规则。没有红雀。没错。核心规则是没有红雀。这也适用于其他动物。这只是一种有趣的代号。但从那以后，我们讨论过很多物种，
especially in relationship to humans and our built environment. And we've gotten a lot of pitches from listeners about animals. For some reason, birds most of all. What is it about birds that gets people like suggesting stories for them? Yeah, I suspect it's partly because bird strikes are such a visible and kind of a traumatizing part of living in cities, and so naturally most of these stories that we do get involve
特别是它们与人类以及我们建造的环境的关系。我们收到了听众关于动物的大量投稿。出于某种原因，鸟类是最多的。究竟是什么吸引人们为它们推荐故事呢？是的，我怀疑部分原因是鸟类撞击是城市生活中一个非常明显且有些创伤性的部分，所以自然地，我们收到的大多数这类故事都涉及
bird deaths and like how to mitigate bird deaths. But it turns out that not everyone is on board with saving birds or at least not every kind of bird. Wait, who's the anti bird out there? Right. What are these cruel people? Yeah. The anti bird. Wait, who's the anti-bird out there? Right. What are these cruel people? Yeah, the anti-bird. The birds are delightful.
鸟类死亡以及如何减轻鸟类死亡。但事实证明，并不是每个人都赞成拯救鸟类，或者至少不是赞成所有种类的鸟类。等等，外面谁是反鸟派？对吧。这些残忍的人是谁？是的。反鸟派。等等，外面谁是反鸟派？对吧。这些残忍的人是谁？是的，反鸟派。鸟儿非常可爱。
Right, but it turns out that some birds are actively targeted for destruction. And here in the US, there's one in particular more than others, the Starling, which isn't even native to North America. Okay, so where do they come from if they're not from North America? So back in the late 1800s, there was a German immigrant named Eugene Sheflin and he was on this mission to introduce birds to North America, but not just any birds.
对，但事实证明，有些鸟类是专门被针对并被消灭的目标。而在美国，有一种鸟比其他鸟更受针对，那就是欧椋鸟，它甚至不是北美本土的鸟类。好的，如果它们不是来自北美，那它们是从哪里来的？所以在 19世纪末，有一位名叫尤金·谢夫林的德国移民，他的使命是将鸟类引入北美，但不仅仅是任何鸟类。
According to lore, he had a specific fondness for European species that had been written about by William Shakespeare. People who were introducing non-native birds, they really like to cite him as inspiration. Like he kind of jazzed people up about these birds. And so around the turn of the 20th century, there were a lot of groups that were aiming to make America look and feel more like Europe, in part by importing familiar plants and animals. And Eugene belonged to one of these groups. It was called the American Aclimatization Society. Huh. So would they just import birds and just release them out in the wild and just kind of hope
根据传说，他特别偏爱威廉·莎士比亚写过的欧洲物种。那些引入非本土鸟类的人，真的很喜欢引用他作为灵感。就像他让人们对这些鸟类充满热情一样。所以在 20世纪之交，有很多组织旨在让美国看起来和感觉更像欧洲，部分原因是通过进口熟悉的植物和动物。尤金就属于这些组织之一。它被称为美国引种协会。哼。所以他们只是进口鸟类，然后把它们放生到野外，并寄希望于
for the best? Yeah. Pretty much. And a lot of these foreign species failed to take off. But some of them, like the Starling, turned out to be really adept survivors. Because Starlings are highly competitive and they're really good at securing prime nesting spots that other birds would normally occupy. Yeah.
一切顺利吗？是的。差不多。其中许多外来物种未能兴起。但其中一些，比如欧椋鸟，被证明是非常精明的幸存者。因为欧椋鸟具有极强的竞争力，而且它们非常擅长抢占其他鸟类通常会占据的优质筑巢地点。是的。
I mean, this is the story when it comes to introducing species. I mean, like, that sometimes they can sort of take over a niche and then they just crowd out all other birds. That's exactly it. And scientists have observed exactly that correlation that as starling populations increase, Bluebird would peck at other bird populations and decrease. Yeah. So I can see why birders would be kind of anti-starling, you know, because they're a fan
我的意思是，这就是引入物种的故事。我的意思是，有时它们可以接管一个生态位，然后它们就会挤走所有其他的鸟类。正是如此。科学家们观察到了完全相同的相关性，即随着欧椋鸟数量的增加，蓝知更鸟会啄食其他鸟类的数量并减少。是的。所以我能理解为什么观鸟者会有点反感欧椋鸟，你知道的，因为他们是其他鸟类的粉丝
of other birds. Right. Right. They want some diversity, and they're not the only ones who are not totally on board with starlings, because it turns out starlings are also a really big pain for the agriculture industry. Not only do they eat grain that's meant for livestock, they're picky about it. They tend to eat the best grain.
。对，对。他们想要一些多样性，而且他们并不是唯一不完全赞同欧椋鸟的人，因为事实证明欧椋鸟对农业界来说也是一个巨大的麻烦。它们不仅吃原本属于牲畜的谷物，而且还很挑剔。它们往往吃最好的谷物。
And this has secondary effects, right? Like reducing the dairy output of cows. Yeah, I can see why farmers would be having a problem with starlings with that was the case. And on their behalf, the US Department of Agriculture has stepped in to mitigate this problem. The USD actually disperses or kills off millions of animals per year.
这会产生连锁反应，对吧？比如减少奶牛的产奶量。是的，如果真是这样的话，我能理解为什么农民会对欧椋鸟感到头疼。为了维护他们的利益，美国农业部已经介入以缓解这个问题。美国农业部实际上每年驱散或消灭数百万只动物。
And from the latest numbers I've seen, starlings are at the top of their hit list. In 2021, they took out thousands of brown tree snakes, tens of thousands of feral pigs, but nearly a million starlings. Wow. That's significant. That's a lot. Yeah, and on top of the ones they kill, they disperse millions more each year. What does that mean?
从我看到的最新数据来看，欧椋鸟排在他们打击名单的榜首。2021 年，他们消灭了数千条褐树蛇、数万头野猪，但消灭了近百万只欧椋鸟。哇。这很显著。数量真多。是的，除了他们杀死的那些之外，他们每年还驱散数百万只。这是什么意思？
That sounds like a euphemism. Well, yeah, for sure. For a great, well, basically, it's like they get them to move away from places that we don't want them, like farms. And they do this using a combination of, you know, recorded sounds and strobing lights, like anything that the birds would find scary
这听起来像是个委婉的说法。嗯，是的，肯定的。为了一个伟大的……嗯，基本上，就像是让他们搬离我们不想要他们去的地方，比如农场。他们通过结合使用（你知道的）录制的声音和闪光灯来做到这一点，任何鸟类会觉得可怕的东西
and, you know, wouldn't want to be your own. Huh. And so do those efforts actually work? Well, it's very much an uphill battle. Today there are still around 200 million starlings in North America. Viewed in that light, the USDA's impact seems actually kind of small. So we did a story a while back about how pigeons got introduced to North America. And now those are like the bird that most people think of as a new sense because we run across them in cities.
，并且（你知道的）不想待在你的地方。哼。那么这些努力真的有效吗？嗯，这是一场非常艰难的斗争。今天北美仍然有大约 2.9 亿只欧椋鸟。从这个角度来看，美国农业部的影响实际上似乎有点微不足道。所以我们前一段时间做过一个关于鸽子是如何被引入北美的故事。现在那些就像是大多数人认为是害虫的鸟，因为我们在城市里会遇到它们。
One of the things we talked about when we talked about pigeons is like, pigeons, it's all about attitude because they're called doves when they're not in cities. And so, I wonder, are there people who see those starlings and don't see them as pests? You don't just see them as like cool birds because they do those like murmurations where they fly through the sky. It's got there's kind of stunning to, you know, to watch. Are there people that are lobbying to protect them, even though they're invasive species?
当我们谈论鸽子时，我们谈论的事情之一是，鸽子完全取决于态度，因为它们不在城市里时被称为鸽子（doves）。所以，我想，有没有人看到那些欧椋鸟并不把它们当成害虫？你不仅仅把它们看作是酷炫的鸟类，因为它们会进行那些像鸟群低语一样的群体飞行，它们飞过天空。这有一种（你知道的）令人惊叹的观赏价值。有没有人在游说保护它们，即使它们是入侵物种？
I mean, not exactly like lobbying to protect them as such, but there are people who point out that starlings might not be as bad for other birds as we think. And so maybe our focus on killing starlings is kind of misplaced because there's a debate around the data. Regarding the impact they have on other bird species and this larger scientific question of correlation versus causation. And so there's a related school of thought
我的意思是，不完全是像那样游说保护它们，但有些人指出，欧椋鸟对其他鸟类的危害可能没有我们想象的那么大。所以也许我们专注于杀死欧椋鸟的做法有点放错了重点，因为数据周围存在争议。关于它们对其他鸟类物种的影响以及相关性与因果关系的更大科学问题。所以有一个相关的思想流派
that maybe instead of running starlings out of town, we should build or grow more habitats for other birds, which makes sense. Right, right. Like we don't have to just kill off starlings. You know, we could just boost other birds and have a healthier ecosystem. Yeah, that's the idea.
，也许我们不应该把欧椋鸟赶出城，而是应该为其他鸟类建造或培育更多的栖息地，这很有道理。对，对。就像我们不必仅仅为了消灭欧椋鸟。你知道的，我们可以简单地扶持其他鸟类并拥有一个更健康的生态系统。是的，就是这个主意。
But of course, farmers wouldn't be too thrilled about giving up the Starling Hunt, which leads me to another type of bird. One that farmers actually liked to have around owls. So I take it that farmers probably like owls because they eat rodents and things like that. Yeah, historically, yes. We like it when birds do things for us, but there are some groups that have taken to,
但当然，农民不会对放弃欧椋鸟狩猎感到太高兴，这让我想到了另一种鸟。一种农民实际上喜欢留宿的鸟——猫头鹰。所以我想农民可能喜欢猫头鹰，因为它们吃啮齿动物之类的东西。是的，历史上确实如此。我们喜欢鸟类为我们做事情，但有一些组织已经开始
you know, building and putting up nesting boxes to help house species like displaced owls, which is independent of their utility to us humans. Yeah, that is nice to see that we shouldn't just treat animals as built environment suitable for us and for them. Because actually, in the end of it all, it needs to be suitable for both us and them for it to be a good, healthy, joyful place to live. Absolutely. And just one other thing before we go, there's a guy who wrote in from the US Fish and Wildlife Service. And he had some really interesting insights too. There are bricks that are specifically built to house certain kinds of birds. They're like, hello. And he also noted that like a lot of birds get stuck in pipes. I mean, there's just a top of the windows that we kind of talked about in the main part of the story. There are just a lot of techniques out there that we could employ to just make the built
建造和安装鸟巢箱来帮助安置像流离失所的猫头鹰这样的物种，这与它们对我们人类的实用性无关。是的，看到这一点很高兴，我们不应该仅仅把动物视为适合我们和它们的建造环境。因为实际上，归根结底，它需要对我们和它们都合适，才能成为一个美好、健康、充满欢乐的居住地。绝对的。在我们离开之前还有一件事，有一个来自美国鱼类及野生动物管理局的家伙写信给我们。他也有一些非常有趣的见解。有些砖块是专门为了容纳某种鸟类而建造的。它们就像是，你好。他还指出，很多鸟类会被困在管道里。我的意思是，除了我们在故事主体中讨论过的窗户外，
environment like a happier place for all kinds of species. Yeah, yeah. This is one of those rare NINI PIs where the design solution is sitting right there. Like if you just have those frited glass, you could save so many bird lives. And the technology is there that just has to be the will and the willingness to spend the money to do it. But as windows get replaced, why not? Just like make everything just a little bit better
还有很多我们可以采用的技术，可以让建筑环境成为对各种物种来说都更快乐的地方。对，对。这是少数几个设计方案就摆在那里的 99PI 之一。就像如果你只是有那些带熔块的玻璃，你就可以拯救无数鸟类的生命。技术就在那里，只需要有这样做的意愿和花钱的意愿。但随着窗户被更换，为什么不呢？只要让一切变得更好一点
for birds, that would be amazing. Yeah, that's exactly it. And there are places in the world where it's like that's part of the mandate that cities have for new architecture, right? Like it's just like part and parcel of building a new building is just making it familiar for animals as well as humans. That's great. Well, thank you for that roundup, Kurt.
为了鸟类，那将是了不起的。是的，完全是这样。世界上有些地方，这是城市对新建筑的要求的一部分，对吧？就像建造新建筑本身就是让动物和人类都觉得熟悉的一部分。那太好了。好吧，谢谢你的总结，库尔特。
I mean, the Cardinal Rule was always a joke. I know, I know. I know. That we didn't do things about birds or any wildlife, but we clearly do things about wildlife all the time because it interacts with our cities and our built world so much that they're actually interesting design conundrums that come about when it comes to the interaction of humans and animals. And, you know, we have like a whole section in our book about it. It is a huge preoccupation of the people on the staff, like it is a huge preoccupation
我的意思是，核心规则一直是个笑话。我知道，我知道。我知道。我们不报道关于鸟类或任何野生动物的事情，但我们显然一直在报道野生动物，因为它们与我们的城市和我们的建筑世界互动太多了，以至于当人类和动物互动时，实际上会出现有趣的设计难题。而且，你知道的，我们的书里有一整章是关于这个的。这是员工们非常关注的一个大问题，就像它是
of the people on the staff. So it's a favorite topic of mine, too. Like I love animals and I love the built environment, so I love places where they intersect. Yeah, that's awesome. Well, thanks so much for this little extra information, Kurt, I appreciate it. Of course.
员工们非常关注的一个大问题。所以这也是我最喜欢的话题。我喜欢动物，我也喜欢建筑环境，所以我喜欢它们交汇的地方。是的，太棒了。好的，非常感谢你提供的这些额外信息，库尔特，我很感激。当然。
99% of us, what was produced this week by Alexander Lang with Chris Baroube, Keko Donald and Kurt Colstead, editing by Delaney Hall, mixed in tech production by Martin Gonzales, music by our director of sound Swan Riau. The Resideme includes Vivian Leigh, Christopher Johnson, Lashemba Dawn, Jason Dillion, Joe Rosenberg, Emmett Fitzgerald, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Alexander Lang first wrote about bird safe design for Bloomberg City Lab. We'll include a link to this article and more of Alexandra's writing at 99pi.org. Special thanks this week to Elizabeth Shapiro, Dan Pazelli, Garrett Crow, NYC Audemont,
99% 的我们，本周节目由亚历山大·朗与克里斯·巴鲁布、凯科·唐纳德和库尔特·科尔斯塔德共同制作，德兰妮·霍尔负责剪辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯负责混音和技术制作，音乐由我们的音响总监天鹅·里乌创作。演员阵容包括维维安·李、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、拉申巴·唐、杰森·狄龙、乔·罗森伯格、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、索菲亚·克拉茨克以及我罗曼·马尔斯。亚历山大·朗最初为彭博社城市实验室撰写了关于鸟类安全设计的文章。我们将在 99pi.org 上附上这篇文章的链接以及亚历山大的更多文章。本周特别感谢伊丽莎白·夏皮罗、丹·帕泽利、加勒特·克劳、纽约奥杜逊学会、
FLAB Canada, and our birders Jera Thorpe, and Catherine Cuell. We are part of the Stitcher and Series XM Podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building, in beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tune me at Roman Mars
加拿大 FLAB、以及我们的观鸟者杰拉·索普和凯瑟琳·库埃尔。我们是 Stitcher 和 SiriusXM 播客家族的一部分，现在总部位于美丽的奥克兰上城潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。您可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并参与有关该节目的讨论。您可以在 Roman Mars 找到我
and the show at 99PI org, or on Instagram and Reddit too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. I can't make serious accents, I'm so like a bird. Serious accents. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并在 99PI org 或 Instagram 和 Reddit 上找到该节目。您可以在 99PI.org 上找到我喜爱的其他 Stitcher 节目的链接以及 99PI 的每一集过往节目。我做不出严肃的口音，我太像一只鸟了。严肃的口音。本集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。